[موسيقى]
انها ثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياض انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
حزمه مساعدات عسكريه غير مسبوقه لاوكرانيا
روسيا تهدد بتدميرها وتغلق باب التفاوض
وتلوح بالنووي
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يشترط اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه قبل اي علاقات دبلوماسيه مع
اسرائيل ويؤكد ضروره الحل السياسي في
سوريا
بعد العقوبات الاوروبيه واشنطن تحضر تهريب
الاموال من العراق الى ايران وتضبط عمليات
غسيل الاموال
الهجمات الالكترونيه تهدد العالم ده روس
يبحث في الاسباب والحلول ويحذر من حدث
سيبراني كارثي وشيك
[موسيقى]
التطورات المتسارعه في مسار الحرب
الاوكرانيه باتت تعكس بما لا يضع مجالا
للشك بان الامور تتجه نحو التصعيد جميع
الاطراف ترجح بان الايام القادمه ستشكل
منعطفا حاسما في الحرب والتلويح بمرحله
جديده لا تستبعد سلاح النووي فعلى جانب
الروسيه تصريحات كلها تصب في خانه التحذير
والتهديد وعلى الجانب الاوكراني فلا
تتوقفوا الدعوات بتسريع التسريح لحسن
المعركه اما الموقف اللافت فجاه من الغرب
هذه المره من خلال حزمه دعم عسكري غير
مسبوقه لاوكرانيا وكانها في سباق لتسليحك
[موسيقى]
نحن بحاجه لا تقديم المزيد عسكريا ولهذا
السبب هناك مناقشات حول انظمه دفاع مضاده
لطائرات انظمه المدفعيه وذخائر قلتها يوم
امس امام البرلمان واكرر النداء اليوم
اعتقد ان الوقت قد حال لتسليم الدبابات
ونرغب في دعمكم لاننا ندركوا ان الاسابيع
القليله القادمه قد تكون حسيمه لما سياتي
بعد ذلك ولهذا السبب اتخاذ القرارات اصبح
ضروري الان
زخم الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا بلغ او وجهه
اليوم بريطانيا وثاني دول اوروبيه تعاهدت
بارسال مساعدات
ثقيله صواريخ انظمه دفاع جوي واسلحه مضاده
للطائرات والكثير من الذخائر لكن المانيا
تحفظت نوعا ما على ارسال الدبابات ورفضت
ارسال انظمتها الخاصه ما لم توافق
الولايات المتحده على ارسال الدباباتها
اولا بحسبه صحيفه عصر الجورنال نقلا عن
مسؤولين المراه
في المقابله ردت روسيا على سيد الدعم
الغربي هذا بتهديد قد ينقل الصراع الى
مرحله جديده وخطيره فقد قال سفير روسيا
لدى الولايات المتحده انا توني انتم ان
الجيش الروسي يدمر اي اسلحه ترسلها دول
الغربيه الى اوكرانيا فيما اعد نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن القومي الروسيه الى الواجهه
ورقه السلاح النووي حيث قال ان هزيمه قوه
النوويه قد تشعل حرب النوويه كلام الرئيس
الروسي السابق جاء على تاكيد حرف النونو
عزمه مواصله امداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
كوسيله لمواصله الضغط على موسكو من اجل
التفاوض
التزيد النووي جاء كذلك على لسان رئيس
جمهوريه الشيشان رمضان قديروف الذي طرح
الموضوع بشكل صريح
روسيا دوله عظمى دوله النوويه ولن تسمح
ابدا لنفسها بالخساره في اي معركه يمكننا
الضغط على الزر والسلام عليكم كما قال
رئيسنا ما الغايه من بقاء العالم انفنيه
روسيا
نتابع مع شبكه مراسله العربيه من برلين
موسكو
طعمه وحذيفه عادل مرحبا بكم جميعا راغده
ابدا معك في برلين لماذا ترهن المانيا
تسليما المزيد من الدعم العسكري الى
اوكرانيا
بتسليم الولايات المتحده اسلحتها اولا
المانيا لا تريد ان ينظر اليها على انها
طرف في تصعيد هذه الحرب هي حريصه جدا على
الا تتخذ اي خطوه يمكن ان تعتبرها همم
روسيا بانها تصعيد من جهه المانيا تحديدا
بسبب يعني العلاقه التاريخيه بين روسيا
والمانيا اذا ما اردنا القول وايضا علاقه
الحزب الاشتراك الحاكم تحديدا ب همم روسيا
هو يعتبر بانه حزب من اكثر الاحزاب
الالمانيه الذي كان مقربا من روسيا وهو
الان حذر جدا في هذه السياسه رغم انه في
اصوات داخل هذه الحكومه من الحسبان
الاخرين المشاركين همم يدعوا ان المستشار
لارسال هذه الدبابات التي تطالب همم بها
همم اوكرانيا ولكن حتى الان ليس هناك اي
التزام صحيح طيب حذيفه
المانيا ولكن هناك دول اوروبيه اخرى سارت
الى تقديم الكثير من الدعم
لاوكرانيا ماذا نعرف عن فصيل هذا الدعم
العسكري الجديد الذي ستحصل عليه اوكرانيا
ومتى يمكن ان يبدا بالوصول
نعم تحياتي صهيب يعني في الحقيقه حزمه
مساعدات كبيره جدا الان تتجه الى اوكرانيا
والى الجيش الاوكراني الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اعلنت عن اكبر حزمه للمساعدات
جزء يسير من هذه الحزمه يعني الحزمه تبلغ
3.75 همم مليار دولار وهذه الجزء يسير
منها يذهب الى الشركاء الذين قدموا سلفا
بعض الانظمه للجيش الاوكراني طبعا على راس
قائمه حزمه المساعدات هو بطاريات باتريوت
المضاده للطائرات كذلك طبعا الذخائر همم
يعني الدقيقه والدخائر 155 مللي كذلك
ذخيره هاي مارس الذي يقاتل الان في صفوف
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وكذلك عدد كبير
من المدرعات وعدد من الذخائر كذلك اليوم
اعلنت بريطانيا عن برنس
600 صاروخ سوف تنقلها الى الجيش الاوكراني
داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه كذلك
وايضا همم مدافع عنها 100 همم
152 وكذلك 62 واثنين
وثمانين كل هذه الاسلحه تنتقل الى الجيش
الاوكراني في الايام القليله الماضيه كذلك
طبعا الدبابات تشالنجر وعدد من المساعدات
الاخرى للجيش الاوكراني قريبا طبعا قمه
رامشتاين غدا سوف تحسم الامور خاصه فيما
يخص ليوبارت الالمانيه قد يكون هنالك حوار
جديد حول هذا الامر هنالك لقاء بين وزير
الدفاع الامريكي ووزير الدفاع الالماني
لمزيد من التشاور حول هذا الامر طيب همم
هنا اسالك اذا راغده من ما انتهى اليه
حذيفه على ما اعتقد هناك اجتماع الجمعه
كذلك في قاعده رمش تايم العسكريه همم ما
المنتظر منه وهذا اللقاء الذي يتحدث عنه
حذيفه هل ستغير المانيا موقفها المتحفظ
قليلا
بالفعل يوم غد هذا الاجتماع وهناك يعني
الكثير يعول على ان يكون هناك تغير في
الموقف الالماني لانه وزير الدفاع
الامريكي اليوم التقي اليس فقط بوزير
الدفاع الالماني ولكن ايضا بالشخص
الالماني او المسؤول الالماني الاول الذي
يتخذ او كان يتخذ في الاشهر الماضيه
قرارات التسليح هو مستشار او رئيس مقر
المستشاريه يدعى فولفو
يعني اقرب مستشاري
الالماني وكان يعني هو من ينصح به ما هي
الاسلحه وما هي السياسه
التسلخيه التي يجب اعتمادها مع اوكرانيا
اصلا التقى بيشمت وكان هناك حوار قبل قليل
كان يتحدث وزير الدفاع الالماني على
القناه الالمانيه الاولى ويقول حتى الان
لم نتخذ قرار ولكن حوار مع شركائنا
الامريكيين لذلك ربما غدا يصدر اي شيء
يلوح الى هذا الامر
الروسي كاتيا
كذلك روسيا تتابع كل هذه الحركه الغربيه
من حلفاء كياب لتسليحها اخر التصريحات
والمواقف الروسيه حي لهذا الدعم الغربي
الجديد لاوكرانيا
والتطورات العسكريه كذلك اليوم على الارض
مرحبا صهيب التطورات الميدانيه اليوم
روسيا اعلنت انها سيطرت على اربعه مناطق
جديده بالقرب من بلده اوريخوف في منطقه
زباروجيا بالاضافه الى على سيطره على
مواقع هامه جدا في منطقه في جنوب دوناس
ايضا خلال همم اليوم الاخير لعمليات
العسكريه او اليوم همم يوم كامل من
العمليات العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
اما اليوم تصريحات كانت حقيقه همم الرد من
قبل نائب مجلس الامن الروسي همم حول
التصريحات الغربيه بتزويد اوكرانيا بيئه
سلاح بمزيد من السلاح كانت طبعا همم جدي
اليوم من قبل الذي قال ان همم هذا التزويد
المستمر هو سيؤدي الى عواقب كثيره طبعا
همم وان خساره دوله نوويه للحرب سيؤدي الى
اشتعال حرب النوويه وهذا ما يده الكرملين
طبعا الكرملين اي ده هذه التصريحات
يعتبرها لا تتعارض مع العقيده النوويه
لروسيا
نعم طبعا الكرمل قال انه تزويد روس
اوكرانيا بسلاح قد يتم استخدامه ضد
الاراسي الاراضي الروسيه سينقل العمليه
العسكريه الى مستوى جديد وسيهدد امن اا
اوروبا بنفسها صهيب لو سمحت في خضام كل
هذا كذلك روسي اريد انها ايضا تحضر لشيء
ما اليوم كان هناك خبر عن اتصال بين
وزيريه دفاع روسيا وبلاروس سيرجيو مع
نظيره البلاسي همم لماذا همم يعني ما الذي
تحدد له روسيا تحديدا
صهيب اليوم اتصل وزير الدفاع الروسيه
بنظره البيلاروسيه طبعا الحديث كان يدور
عن مجموعات
الاقليميه المشتركه بين البلديه البلدين
وطبعا عن التحضير لقوات ردع في حال كان
هناك تهديد لبيلاروسيا وهذا ما اكد عليه
اليوم وزير الخارجيه الروسي ايضا بالتوازي
يزوره مسك والتقابي نظيره البيلاروسيه
ورئيس ميرا روسيا ايضا تحدث عن ان هذه
القوات المشتركه هي تاتي في الوقت المناسب
ثم انشائها الوقوف في وجه اي تهديدات
تشكلها الدول الغربيه على بلاروسيا قوات
الردع المشتركه همم طبعا التي ستكون همم
في بيلاروسيا في حال كان هناك اي تهديد او
هجوم من قبل بولندا او الدول المجاوره
لبلاروسيا صهيب مراسلين العربيه
طعمه حذيفه عادل ورغد بهنام شكرا جزيلا
لكم
[موسيقى]
وعلى وقع كل هذا التصعيد يبدو بان بابا
تفوضى بين روسيا واوكرانيا حول ايجاد
تسويه للحرب سيغلق نهائيا فبعد الكثير من
الشد والجذب خرج مسؤول الروسي ليقطع الشك
باليقين ويؤكد بالحرف انه لا تسوي على
الاطلاق مع اوكرانيا التصريح جاء من
القائم باعمال مندوب روسيا لدى الاتحاد
الاوروبيينوف الذي نفى اي اتصالات بين
ممثلين روسيا والاتحاد الاوروبي بشان
التفاوضي لان هاء الحرب
تصريحات المسؤول الروسي جاء تفضلن على
اعلان السكرتير مجلس الامن القومي والدفاع
الاخراني اليكسي داني لوف بان بلاده تلقت
عروض للدخول في تسويه للازمه الاوكرانيه
تشبه سيناريو تسويه الازمه الكوريه
والصيغه الكوريه مشاهدينا تعني الاتفاق
الذي تم على اساسه حل النزاعي بين سول
وبيونغ يونغ سنه 53 وانتهى بتقسيم شبه
الجزيره الكوريه الى شمال
[موسيقى]
واجه الرجل الذي كرم لانه انقذ
مصيرا ماساويا قتل على يد شعبه مكافحه
التجسس بشبهه الخيانه في وسط عاصم جورنا
نقلت مزيدا من تفاصيل القصه الجدليه
قبل اسابيع من مرور عام على بدء العمليه
الروسيه ضد اوكرانيا عادل للاذهان مشهد
جثه برصاصه في الجمجمه ملقاه على رصيف وسط
العاصمه كيف
القتيل لم يكن مواطنا اوكرانيا عاديه
مقتله اثار جدلا واسعا فهل
جاسوس روسي ان بطل تساؤلات لصحيفه
واستخبارات
انضم لمفاوضات السلام في ال 28 من فبراير
في بيلاروسيا في دور غير محدد الا ان
حضوره كان بطلب من الجانبين عده روايات
ومراسم دفن غير اعتياديه فمسول جهاز الامن
الاوكرانيه قال حينها ان دينيس كريف قتل
بصفته خائنا لتجسسه لصالح موسكو لكن بعد
ايام من القائل جثتي كريم الذي وصف
بالجاسوس وقتل على اساس ذلك دفنا بطلا
بجوار اول وزير خارجيه لاوكرانيا ووقع
الرئيس الاوكراني اوراق لمنحه وساما
لواجبه الاستثنائي في الدفاع عن سياده
الدوله
تقديرا لجهوده في الحيلوله دون تقدم
القوات الروسيه نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه
فبراير العام الماضي بفضل معلومات بغايه
الدقه نقلها كريف من اتصالاته مع الروس
دورا الداهو الدينس كريم لم تنكره الجهات
الرسميه الا ان وفاته دفعت موسكو وكياف
للتحفظ على التعليق دفن مع مرتبه الشرف
العسكريه ومعه سره الا انه على مدى اشهر
ثلاث مقتله فتحت اوكرانيا اكثر من 650
قضيه خيانه تورط فيها مسؤولون حكوميون
روان حمزه العربيه
[موسيقى]
ونبقى في اوكرانيا الاوكرانيا يستعيلون
بخبره الكمبوديين في ازاله الالغام فكم
بوديا تعد احد اكثر البلدان التي تعرف
انتشارا للالغام في العالم وهو ما اكسب
خبرائهم تجربه كبيره حاولوا نقلها للجنود
الاوكرانيين
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه اكثر من مليون
فرنسيه تظاهروا في عموم البلاد ضد مشروعي
المشروع الحكوميه نظام التقاعد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحانين الاتفاق
على اقامه دوله فلسطينيه سيكون شرطا مسبقا
لاقامه علاقات دبلوماسيه الرسميه مع
اسرائيل وقال الامير فيصل بن فرحان في
مقابله مع التلفزيون
الحقيقي في المنطقه لا يتحقق الا من خلال
اعطاء الامل للفلسطينيين مشيرا الى ان ذلك
ياتي من خلال منح الفلسطينيين دولتهم وفي
سياق اخر قال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه انه
يجب العمل للوصول الى حاليا سياسي الى
ازمه السوريه مشيرا الى انه يتم التعاون
مع الشركاء لاكتشاف طريقه للتعامل مع
الحكومه في دمشق كما اشار الى ان الولايات
المتحده تعد الشركه الامنيه الاكثر نشاطا
في المنطقه
تجاري مهم للمملكه وحول الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه اكد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه ان
الرياض ترى امكانيه لانهاء الحرب
بالمفاوضات واضاف ان السعوديه تعمل مع
روسيا للحفاظ على سعر النفط مستقرا نسبي
ا ماريونس ثاني اقدم اسير سياسيه في
العالم يعانق الحريه بعد اربعين عاما
قضاها في سجون الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خرج
قبله باسبوعين ابن عمه كريم يونس لكن ماهر
وكريم تركا خلفهما خمسه الاف اسيل
فلسطينيه
عاما احتضنت والده الاسير الحاجه وداد
يونس البالغ من العمر
88 عاما نجلها اليوم لاول مره
شعوري لا لا يوصف بعيد 40 سنه ضميته
حبيبي بيتزوج
ماهر وكريم يونس اولاد العم واصدقاء الصبا
وبعد ان امضيات طفولتهما سويا
زملاء في السجن لاربعين عاما اليوم
يلتقيان وهما يتنفسان الحريه
هذا شعور لا يوصف وان كنا يعني لا يمكن
الوصفه يعني كل اللغه العربيه لا يمكن وصف
الشعور هذا اييه شعور طبعا طيب والاستقبال
ما شاء الله الحمد لله شفت الاهل وشفت
الاصدقاء ومن عاشروني في الاسير يعني كمان
كنت انا بالبيت عندهم وهو من بيت عنا
واحنا كمان تعلمنا سوا في نفس المدرسه
والاخره وتغربنا سوا وكمان رفاق نضال بدنا
نروح عند زميل او صديق مشترك وحسناتنا
انه يمكن نزور بيوت اسرى اخرين عن زورهم
ان شاء الله سوا بعد ان وجهها ماهر رساله
للشعب الفلسطيني
التي تهتف باسمي فلسطين
عشرات الفلسطينيين اتو من القدس وام الفحم
وعكا والمدن المجاوره لتقديم التهاني
والتبريكات للاسير ماهر يونس على الرغم من
قرار وزير الامن القومي المتطرف اتمرن
كبير منع مظاهر الاحتفال ورفع الاعلام
الفلسطينيه احتفل عدد كبير من الفلسطينيين
بتحرير الاسير ماهر يونس والذي امضى
اربعين عاما في السجون الاسرائيليه لا
نكون غازي من قريه عراء العربيه
[موسيقى]
الى الملف الايرانيه الان سيل العقوبات
المسلطه على ايران لا يزالوا متواصلا
ودفعه جديده من الاتحاد الاوروبي قد ترى
نور قريبا هذه المره فان طهران قد تواجه
عقوبه شديده بعد ما صوت البرلمان الاوروبي
لصالح قرار يدعو الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
ادراج الحرس الثوري في قائمه المنظمات
الارهابيه وقبل قليل افادت مصادر
الدبلوماسيه ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يعمل على
تصنيف الحرس الثوري منظمه ارهابيه دعوه
البرلمان الاوروبيه
فعلا قلقه في طهران الرئيس الايراني رئيسي
قال ان سعيا الاتحاد الاوروبي لادراج
الحرس الثوري على لائحه الارهاب يتعارض مع
القوانين الدوليه وميثاق الامم المتحده
اما وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد
الله الان فاجر بهذا الخصوص محادثات
هاتفيه مع الممثل الاعلى لسياسه الخارجيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيفوريل انتقد فيه عبد
الحيان بشده ما اسمه النهج المتوتر
والانفعالي للبرلمان الاوروبي واعتبر
سلوكه غير مدروس وخطا
هيئته اركان الجيش الايراني بدورها تفاعلت
مع القرار من قبل البرلمان الاوروبي حيث
حذرت اوروبا من ادراج الحرس الثوري على
قائمه الارهاب معتبره ان في ذلك تهديدا
للامن القومي والدولي التي هذا او هذه
التطورات تاتي بينما اكد ذلك التماسيون ان
ممثلي الدول الاعضاء الاوروبي واثق
بالاجماع على فرد عقوبات على ايران
[موسيقى]
معنى مين بروكسيل مراسله العربيه الاردني
معنا ما الذي سيترتب على قرار البرلمان
الاوروبي ادراج الحرس الثوري على قائمه
الارهاب
عنه تداعيات سياسيه لان هذا القرار يمثل
اولا وقبل كل شيء اشاره سياسيه غير مسبوقه
من البرلمان الاوروبي في اتجاه الدول
الاعضاء وخاصه في اتجاه ايران وان هذا
الضغط الذي يشكله هذا القرار يعني يشبه
الى حد ما اقصى الضغط او سياسه اقصد الضغط
التي مارستها اداره الرئيس ترامب وتتواصل
الى حد كبير مع الرئيس ضد ايران هذا
القرار يستخدمه جوزيف بوريل في التواصل مع
امير عبد الحي وزير الخارجيه الايراني
ابلاغه بان بان الراي العام الاوروبي مجمع
حول هذه المسائل وان على ايران ان توقف
سلوكياتها سواء كانما يتعلق بقمع
المتظاهرين وقت دعم روسيا عدم تدخلها في
الشؤون بالتالي هناك نوع من القلق الكبير
جدا في البرلمان الذي سيكون في صالح
دليلا في حديثه مع عبد الحي وهم يعني
بينهما قناه تواصل اتصال ايضا تستخدمه
الدول التي تريده تستخدمه الدول مثل
المانيا وهولندا وجمهوريه تشيك الدول
الثلاث تريد همم او ترغبوا فيه ادراجي
الحرس الثوري على قائمه الارهاب لكن
القضيه لا تزالوا قيد البحث على الصعيد
الدبلوماسي في هذه المرحله لان مثل هذه
الموقف يتطلبوا همم فتره من الزمن بسبب
التعقيدات القانونيه التي يجب اعدادها
مسبقا قبل الوصول الى القرار النهائي
من هناك ان قرار البرلمان يدعم ايضا توجه
المانيا هولندا جمهوريه تشيك طيب
هذا عن الحرس الثوري وادراجه في قوائم
الارهاب الاوروبيه اضافه الى ذلك ماذا عن
العقوبات المنتظره على ما اعتقد هناك يوم
الاثنين المقبل سيكون هناك تصويت من قبل
وزراء الخارجيه همم في الاتحاد الاوروبي
على الحزمه الرابعه من العقوبه ضد ايران
ما المنتظر
اولا هناك توافق سياسي بين الدول الاعضاء
ال 27 على هذه الحزمه الرابعه من العقوبات
ضد ايران
تشمل حسب بعض المصادر 17 مسؤولا ضمن منهم
وزير الرياضه او عدد من ضباط الحرس الثوري
الايراني تشمل عدد من المؤسسات منها هيئه
الاذاعه والتلفزيون هيئه الاتصالات اي
شركات التي تعمل على اعاقه انسياب
المعلومه بين الايرانيين ايضا همم هناك في
هذه القائمه المنتخب يوم الاثنين 20 كيانا
اضافيا يضافون الى قوائم العقوبات من بين
هؤلاء من بين هذه الكائنات ال 20 همم 12
12 كيانا تقريبا ينتمون الى الحارس السوري
الايراني هناك اذا قوائم طويله من
العقوبات سواء كان الارهاب حقوق الانسان
همم سوريا همم تكنولوجيا صواريخ النوويه
وفي هذه العقوبه القوائم كافه نجد اسماء
الضباط وعدد كبير من الضباط الايرانيين
الاردن وفريده مباشره من بروكسيل شكرا
جزيلا
[موسيقى]
اذا كما استمعنا العقوبات تحاصر ايران من
كل الجهات هذه المره فان الحضره يشمل
الاموال المهربه من العراق صحيفه وصف
الجورنال كشفت ان
واشنطن ابلغت همم اذا همم
ابلغت اذا بانها ستقوم بايقاف تهريب
العمله الى ايران بشكل فوري واضافت
الصحيفه ان وزاره الخزانه والبريد
الفيدرالي الامريكي
المركزي العراقي
بمنع اربعه مصارف اذن من التعامل
ببيع هذه العمله ايضا
وعن اسباب هذا المنع توضح الصحيفه صحيفه
نقلا عن مسؤولين امريكيين بان الغرض هو
وضع حد لعمليات غسل الاموال التي تقوم بها
طهران ودمشق عن طريق العراق هذا فضلا عن
منع الجهات المشبوهه في ايران استخدام
المصارف العراقيه لتحويل اموالها كما كشفت
الصحيفه نقلا عن مصرتين عن وجود عمليات
تحويل اموال بالدولار بناء على فواتير
مزوره خارج العراق لمجهوله
حقيقه انه موضوع ارتفاع الدولار او
بالحقيقه هي بالاتجاه المعاكس هو ارض
انخفاض العمله العراقيه هو نتيجه همم خروج
اموال طائله من الدولار
والرصيد الموجود في البنوك العراقيه خارج
البلدان نتيجه تهريب او نتيجه طرق غير
مشروعه او حوالات غير رسميه او غسيل اموال
فهذا ما ادى الى ارتفاع نسبه همم الدولار
امام الدينار العراقي شيء اكيد هذا
التهريبي ياثر الارتفاع الدولار كان احنا
كاصحاب محلات اليوم يعني احنا سوقنا كلش
تعب من وراء الدولار ومن وراء تهريب
الدولار تهريب الدولار من البلد اللي
يعتبر
قوميه كبيره همم يؤثر بشكل همم سلبي على
ارتفاع الاسعار في الاسواق المحليه وايضا
يؤثر على المواطن العراقي باعتباره فرض
مستهلك لل- همم همم للحاديات الاساسيه
التي يعني يحتاجها
من لندن معنا صادق الركابي مدير المركز
العالمي للدراسات التنمويه مرحبا بك معنا
استاذ صادق اجراءات امنيه امريكيه اذا
مشدده تمنع تبييض الاموال وتحويل
الدولارات من العراق الى ايران هل ستكون
ناجحه برايك
نعم تحيه لكم بالفعل بدات تاخذ مفعوله هي
ناجحه بالنسبه للحد من الفساد وتهريب
الاموال بدايه لنبدا من التقارير التي
صدرت ليس من الاداره الامريكيه وان مع من
الاداره الماليه العراقيه قبل عام صدر من
دائره الوقايه في هيئه النزاهه العراقيه
تقرير اشاره بوضوح الى ان معظم الفواتير
التي يتم بموجبها استيراد السلع عبر نافذه
بير العمله في البنك المركزي هي فواتير
مزوره وقال بان حجم الضرر على الخزينه لا
يقل عن اربعه مليون دينار عراقي وهو رقم
جدا كبير هذا من المصادر العراقيه نفسها
ثم جاءت الخزانه الامريكيه لتفرد هذه
الرقابه الشديده التي من خلال المنصه
الجديده التي يرفض بعض المصريين ان
يشتركون فيها خشيه ان يتعرضون للعقوبات
هذه المنصه تحتاج الى عمليه اسبوعين على
اقل تقدير حتى يتم البث في الموافقه من
قبل المكتب الاصول الخارجيه في الخزانه
الامريكيه ثم يرسل اشعارا الى البنك
المركزي وهذا جعل عمليه الدولار المخصص
لاستيراد السلع تقل في السوق وتتم عمليات
السحب الان من الدولار الموجود في الاسواق
للمسافرين والطلاب طيب
القرار هذا الامريكي كيف سينعكس على
الواقع المعيشي للعراقيين بالنسبه للتضخم
خصوصا للاسعار داخل العراق وكيف سيانعكس
كذلك على ايران
طيب قبل ان اشرح انعكاسه يجب ان نشير الى
نقطه انه في العام 2015 كان الحجم الكلي
لاستيراد ال ال السلع في العراق المخصص
يوميا كان بحدود 75 مليون دولار الغريب
انه ارتفع في غضون اعوام قليله الى قرابه
300 مليون دولار وهذا يعطيك دليل على ان
هناك الكثير من الاستيرادات الغير حقيقيه
الان النقص في الدولار هذا نقص في الدولار
لان العراق بلد غير منتج ويحتاج الى
الكثير من الاستيراد بدا ينعكس على ارتفاع
بعض السلع التي يتم استيرادها وبالتالي
الان ال- ال- الدينار العراقي قيمته
تتراجع والدولار اصبح ملادا يعني اشبه
بالذهب بالنسبه للكثيرين والكل يريد
الحصول عليه وهذا الامر سيرفع من اسعار
الدولار المستقبل
التي حدثت في البصره كان هناك
ابداعات واضحه من الجمهور العراقي للسيد
محمد الشيعه السوداني بالعمل على تخفيض
الدولار وهذا يعطيك ان هناك بالفعل غضب
حقيقي وقلق لدى المواطن العراقي من هذا
الامر نعم وبنسبه لايران
الان الايران الان محرجه لانه هناك لديها
حاله من التضخم في الاسعار
اليها الفواتير المزوره بدا يقل وبالتالي
تعمل على سحب الدولار الذي يباع عبر
المنافذ المتاح على المسافرين وغيره من
الطلبه وبالتالي هذا يعني يتم عبر القنوات
التي كردستان مثلا او قنوات السفر عن طريق
دبلوماسيين عبر الطائرات وهذا كله سوف
يؤدي الى يعني تقليص قيمه الدولار في
العراق وايران تحاول ان تعوض هذا ناقص
ولكنها لن تعوض القيمه التي كانت تحصل
عليها من فواتير الاستيراد سابقه نعم ما
زال على ما يبدو معي القليل من الوقت يريد
ان نستفسر منك اعود الى نقطه التضخم في
العراق يعني ما علاقه هذا القرار همم مع
همم يعني ارتفاع الاسعار في العراق
لانه لان العراق بلد غير منتج فهو يحتاج
الى استيراد مواد اوليه الى الصناعه يحتاج
الى استيراد مثلا حتى حليب الاطفال يتم
استيراده في العراق وبالتالي قله وجود
الدولار المخصص للاستيراد هذا يجعل عدم
الاستيراد غير كافي وبالتالي السلع
الموجوده حاليا حتى التجار يرفضون ان
يبيعوها لانهم اشتروها باسعار همم سابقا
غير الاسعار التي هي موجوده حاليا ولا
يريدون ان يتعرض للخسائر وبالتالي هذا رفع
من الاسعار المعروض قال في السوق العراقيه
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك صديق الركابي مدير
المركز العالمي للدراسات التنمويه كنت
معنا من لندن
[موسيقى]
اعلن مصدر في الشرطه الفرنسيه
احتجاجا على رفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما
الى 64
واستخدمت شرطه فارس
الحكومه لرفع سن التقاعد وتمثل الاضرابات
والاحتجاجات واختبارا جديده لرئيس المرمى
الذي يقول ان خطته لاصلاح نظام التقاعد
الضروريه للضمان عدم الافلاس ويتعهد
بالمضيق قدما في الخطه رغم هذه التظاهره
موجه احتجاج عارمه تشهدها شوارع العاصمه
باريس احتجاجا على رفع سن التقاعد هذه
الموجه هي الاولى من ثلاث موجات ستكون
الثانيه الاسبوع المقبل وتستمر ليومين اما
الثالثه فستكون في السادس من شهر فبراير
وستمر
لثلاثه ايام هذا التحرك كان وليد اتفاق
بين ثمان نقبات عماليه دعمته جبهه يسريه
موحد ضمت كل الاحزاب وتواجد ممثلها في
الشارع ما جعل صوره التظاهرات استثنائيه
ونادره واعترفت الشرطه بانها مليونيه
الصغار انا متقاعد في الاصل لكن اتمنى ان
يحصل اطفال على التقاعد نفسه الذي حصل
عليه
وكما جرت العاده سرعان ما تحولت الشوارع
الى ساحه مواجهه عندما حاولت الشرطه تقسيم
الموكب الضخم الى مواكب يسهل تفريقها
محاوله اثارت غضب مجموعات شبابيه فرقتها
الشرطه بالغاز المسيء للدموع وباعتقال بعض
افرادها واصابه اخرين نقل بعضهم الى الحجز
رغم اصاباتهم
اصحاب الدخل المحدود يعيشون حياه صعبه
بايجازه محدوده و لديهم تقاعد باس هذا غير
عادل ولهذا السبب انا هنا اليوم
الفرنسيين في الشارع حكومته لاخذ خطوه الى
الوراء ذلك فعلته حكومه جاك شيراك عام
1995 عندما فكر الرئيس الراحل برفع سن
التقاعد لكن الحكومه الحاليه اعلنت مسبقا
انها لن تتراجع
العربيه باريس
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه العراق بين فرحه
التتويج بلقب كاس الخليج 25 وماساه
التدافع قبل المباراه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مع اتفاق من مخاطر
الهجمات الالكترونيه في العالم او لا
منتدى
لمحاولات الهجوم
من ان عدم الاستقرار السياسي يفاقم مخاطر
الهجمات الالكترونيه وبالتالي يؤثر على
قرارات في الشركات والمستثمرين وبينما لا
تزيد قدرته المجرمين السبراني
التحتيه الرقميه
وفي تقرير توقعات الامن السيبراني العالمي
لعام 2023 الذي اصدره المنتدى يرجح خبراء
الامن السيبراني احتماله وقوع حدث
سيبرانيا كارثي في العامين المقبلين وقد
شهدت الاشهر الماضيه عدد من الهجمات
السبرانيه حول العالم كذلك التي عرفلت
خدمه البريد في المملكه المتحده لمده
اسبوعين واخرى استهدفت مستشفيات على نطاق
واسع في الولايات المتحده وهجمات كتفت
الضغوط العسكريه على اوكرانيا التقرير
خلصا الى ان السبيل الامثل لمواجهه
التهديدات السبرانيه هو الاستثمار
التقنيات الجديده وتسخير الذكاء الاصطناعي
في التصدي للاجرام الرقم بالاضافه الى
سرعه انتاج التقنيه الجديده اللازمه
[موسيقى]
في العراق توجد قبل قليل المنتخب العراقي
بلقب بطوله كاس الخليج الخامسه والعشرين
التي اقيمت في البصره وجاء ذلك بعد الفوز
على نظيره العماني
اذا بنتيجه ثلاثه اهداف مقابل هدفك
لكن وسط الفرحه العراقيه حادث تدافع الذي
وقع قبيل المباراه بساعات تلقي بظلالها
على المشهد فحتى الان اعلن عن قتيل واحد
على الاقل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ده ذكر المتحدث باسم الحكومه البريطانيه
ان رئيس الوزراء ريشي سوناك يعتذر عن عدم
وضعه لحزام الامان اثناء استقلاله سياره
وتصويره لمقطع نشر على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وذلك عقب تداول المستخدمين
المواقع مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي للمقطع
متسائلين عن ما اذا كان رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني يتمتع باي استثناءات تعفيه من
دفع غرامه عدم ربط حزام الامان الامر الذي
جعله يعتذر على ذلك
[موسيقى]
قدرت الوكاله الفيدراليه الامريكيه لاداره
الطوارئ ان سلسله عواصف كاليفورنيا قد
تكلف الولايات المتحده والولايه بالذات
مئات الملايين من الدولارات مع توقعاتهم
ارتفاع الخسائر لاعلى من ذلك هذا وخلفت
هذه العواصف والفيضانات التي ضربت
كاليفورنيا اكثر من 20 قتيلا
وفي افغانستان ارتفع عدد الوفيات جراء
موجه البرد القارس لتصل الى 88 شخص قامت
موجه البرد لازمه الانسانيه في ظل نقص
الغذائي والماوى من جانبها اعلنت وزارهه
اداره الكوارث الطبيعيه في افغانستان عن
نفوقي اكثر من 75,000 راس من الماشيه
نتيجه للبرت
[موسيقى]
هذه هي نهايه اخبار الساعه لهذه الليله
اليكم تذكيرا بابرزها
حزمه مساعدات عسكريه غير مسبوقه لاوكرانيا
روسيا تهدد بتدميرها وتغلق باب التفاوض
وتلوح بالنووي
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يشترط اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه قبل اي علاقات دبلوماسيه مع
اسرائيل ويؤكد ضروره الحل السياسي في
سوريا
بعد العقوبات الاوروبيه واشنطن تحضر تهريب
الاموال من العراق الى ايران وتضبط عمليات
غسيل اموال
الهجمات الالكترونيه تهدد العالم دابوس
يبحث في الاسباب والحلول ويحذر من حدث
سيبراني كارثي وشيكه
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده المزيد دائما
يبقى العربيه دوت نت على صفحتنا على مواقع
التواصل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]